[Music]
there do I see my mother
hold there do I see my father
oh they're do they call to me oh they're
do they call to me
oh they're do they call to me
that Bo's a little big for you isn't it
my mother made me shed I'd go into it
[Music]
find your way home
you are free we're taking your ashes to
the highest peak in the realms ashes it
was your last wish
well must we go to a realm beyond your
own there's only one person can get you
where you need to go
they call me Mamiya smartest man alive
first you need to cut off my head wait
what that axe you get you got a handle
or special I know you're a guy not of
this room but there's no mistaking it he
doesn't know does he about your true
nature or his own the longer you wait
the more damage you do he will resent
you and you may lose him forever there
are consequences to killing a guard
[Music]
power of this weapon any weapon comes
from here would only win tempered by
this the self-control with the one who
wields it
[Music]
what are your health this is no ordinary
illness
the boy is true nature your true nature
fights within him
[Music]
so momenta like you know we are not men
we are more than that the responsibility
is far greater
[Music]
[Music]
can you kill something that big
[Music]
pre-or and get three shields constrain
game